CONNOR McDAVID OF EDMONTON, SIT
BACK AND ENJOY THIS ONE.
OFF, IT LEAKS THROUGH EITHER WA
AS THE PUCK
LEFT FOR DONATO.
HIS CHANCE ON THE SHORT SIDE,
STOPPED BYARDS.
MARCUS JOHANSSON, BROKEN UP,
CONNOR McDAVID TAKES IT IN. EBE
IN FRONT OF THE GOAL, FORMER
MIDDLE, SEE THE POINT, McCANN
KNOWS HOW NICE A PASS EVAN BOUC
POINT, WILL DEFLECTION, NOT
SURE.
MAYBE OFF THE GLOVE AND NEAR
WALL, TYLER BENSON FOR THE
OILERS, KNOCKEDFORSLUND, JT BRO
SHAW WITH US
EDMONTON NUMBER ONE WITH POWER
PLAY OVERALL ANDCLOCK, DRAISAITF
BODIES IN KICKED OUT, THEY SCORE
ON THEMER OFF
THE PAD, RIGHT TO FOEGELE.
CALL IT A P PK IN THE SEATTLE
ZONE.ILL TAKE IT BACK.
TIGHT TURN ON COLTON SCEVIOUR,
WILL STETE BENCH.
PERLINI.
DROPS IT OFF.
PEPPERING BY DRAI
BREAKOUT.
FOEGEL FOR DUNN.
THIS WAY IT'S SCHWARTZ,, BIG GO
ABLE TO GET OVER
SCEVIOUR PICKSK
BOUNCES IN FRONT.
McDAVID TRIES TO GET A PIECEHE
CHALLENGED BY THIS.
DUNN, A REBOUND, SOUCY SCORES!
BIT OF
COMES McDAVID, THROUGH THE
CENTER   KRAKEN.
THIS IS RYAN
BOUCHARD, KOEKKOEK OFF THE
THE PUCK WAS ALREADY
GOING OVER DRIEDGER'S SHOULDER
WE HAVE A VERDICT.
WE'LL GET THE REVIEW,
EDMONTON CHALLENGED THE PLAY FOR
NO GOALTENDERNET, McDAVID, ROAR.
McDAVID FENDS IT